why
so with original sin issue number three
what we see here is that we're picking
up almost immediately after the events
of original sin issue number two but
this issue is very very important for
the original sin storyline and the
reason why is because this storyline
will not just lay the foundation for
future actions and the storyline
involving other characters as well as
the tie-ins but it will also pertain to
the production or I guess introduction
of newer characters in the realm of
Marvel Comics as a whole and this will
become doubly so when we get to this
section of original sin where we talk
about what it was that Nick Fury had
said to Thor that caused him to lose the
ability to wield his hammer and what we
see going on here is that again this
takes place immediately after original
sin issue number two and so we're all
these members of the superhero community
the Avengers and some of the x-men had
gathered to confront dr. Midas and the
orb the orb in turn uses the powers of
the Watchers eye to expose everyone's
secrets and what we see here is that a
vast array of things are going on here
there is now new information in the
minds of various superheroes involving
other people all these secrets that
belong to anybody they had ever known
are now inside their heads and so they
know everything now with regards to the
Incredible Hulk what we will see and
hope versus Iron Man is that we'll see
this sort of storyline playing out
whereby we get a little more information
in terms of how it was that Bruce Banner
became the Incredible Hulk in the first
place and when we get into the story of
spider-man we'll learn about the these
circumstances that led to spider-man or
Peter Parker becoming spider-man and the
fact that he was not the only one that
this happened to from here what we see
going on is that dr. Midas oubliette and
in the orb or attempting to make their
getaway as a result of the fact that the
superheroes for the most part are
entirely distracted by the fact that
they're seekers have been laid bare but
what we see is that before the org can
get away he's confronted by Nick Fury
and Nick Fury tells him to put his hands
on his head and that he's under arrest
for murder what we see here with the orb
is the orb says there's no need for that
that he's not the one that nick fury's
after that the orb wants to know who
killed the watcher just as much as Nick
Fury does because it wasn't the orb who
did it from here we transition back to
do black panther Emma Frost and Scott
Lang and what we see here is that
they're talking about the idea of these
bullets that they've collected through
the corpses of these bodies these
gamma-irradiated bullets and we see them
talking about how all these different
creatures all these different I guess
monsters or mutants or what-have-you are
here but somebody had put them here and
if somebody had the power to kill these
things and somebody must have been doing
this for a very long time and the
question has to be asked what does this
have to do how does this tie in to the
watcher being killed on the moon we see
black panther telling us that again our
killer that the killer that has
eliminated all these monsters has been
doing this for a while and has the
skills to remain hidden and so he says
that perhaps the watcher was killed
because the watcher saw this happening
the watcher saw that this individual was
killing all these things and as a result
the watcher lost his life because of it
Emma Frost goes as far as to ask the
question was it because he saw the
killer is that the most likely case and
black panther replies that the watcher
sees everything even the unseen now the
unseen is a very important element with
regards to this comic and again I'd like
you to keep this in the back of your
head because what we will see later on
as we get into or I guess as we progress
further is that we'll learn what the
unseen is from here we transition back
to Doctor Strange and the Punisher and
the Punisher says that this individual
was shot from some distance away that
more likely most likely it was somewhere
around maybe 4,000 yards and that
regardless of the kind of gun that was
used it would take an incredibly
accurate person to pull off a shot like
this Frank Frank Castle says that this
going to be done by a handful of people
on the planet earth that maybe 10 people
actually have this skill to do this from
here we see a doctor strange pondering
this information dr. strange simply
saying that this is a little weird this
is a little strange and he's a little um
dissatisfied by the fact that there are
killers that are roaming these
dimensions and he doesn't really know
what the ramifications that this could
be regarding other dimensions we see a
frank castle rule asking dr. strange if
dr. strange referring to him and dr.
strange says what's the difference he
says there's really no difference
between frank castle and whoever this
anonymous killer is where Frank Castle
says that when he kills somebody he
doesn't hide it which of course is
something that at that were quite aware
of reading through the The Punisher
comics what we see here is that dr.
strange then tells Nick Fury I'm sorry
tells of the Punisher that if only ten
people are able to kill on this scale
are able to kill somebody from this far
away with this level of preciseness then
he wants to know who they are he wants
the exact list of those individuals that
are capable of this kind of thing from
here we switched to Bucky Barnes Moon
Knight and Gomorrha and again these
individuals are conducting their
investigation off the planet Earth or
investigating space as a whole
but at this point in the story they
haven't really encountered anything yet
where Emma Frost and black panther and
Scott Lang had traveled to the center of
the earth and encountered aliens and
monsters that have been killed and
Doctor Strange and Punisher had
encountered their own sort of extra
dimensional beings we see that for the
most part Gamora and Moon Knight and
Bucky Barnes haven't found anything and
because they have a family thing they
feel like this is a fool's errand Gamora
says that this is silly she says there's
really no need for them to be here that
if they're going to be looking for the
murder of The Watcher there really be no
reason why the murderer would be out in
space the The Watcher was on the moon
and so most likely the murderer is on
the planet Earth or hails from the
planet Earth
and that they should be investigating
the earth instead what we see here is
this this weird kind of circumstance
where the the ship that they're
traveling in begins to encounter all
these bullets they begin to effectively
fly into a field of bullets and the
shell casings and for the most part
they're not really sure what in the
world's going on here they don't really
understand how it is they're flying in a
bullet casings but they continue to
follow the trail from here we see that
again they're reporting there and
they're in for
they're reporting their investigation to
an anonymous individual who we can't see
and for the most part we're led to
believe that this is the same individual
that had given their information or
given the information to black panther
that had set this entire investigation
in motion and a first place then what we
see with this individual is that he's
saying it won't be long he's talking to
reassume a henchman of some kind and
says that they need to make things ready
for when their visitors arrive that they
need to prepare for the worst should the
worst happen in addition he says that
they're going to need a lot more of
these gamma-irradiated bullets
indicating to us that perhaps this
unknown individual is the one behind the
entire conflict in the first place from
here what we see is the orb and the orb
is being interrogated so to speak by
Wolverine and The Incredible Hulk and
again this isn't necessarily a torture
session of any kind whereby they're
actually inflicting harm but they're
both using their extreme physical
prowess will rein in his violence and
The Incredible Hulk with his sheer
strength to to attempt to threaten the
orb to try to get the orb to confess to
try to get him to tell them what in the
world's been going on but what we see
here is that the orb says that while
they're looking for the person who
killed the watcher while they're looking
for this individual that he will not
give them any information that the only
person he wants to talk to his Nick Fury
and that unless they bring him Nick Fury
he's not going to say anything from here
we see that again the information this
interrogation is being seen by some some
individual which of course is uh I guess
introduced to us as Nick Fury now what
it is that Nick Fury is actually doing
here what it is that he's actually
monitoring is a little strange because
what we see for the most part is that
he's keeping an eye on everything he's
monitoring everything that has gone on
here we see for the most part that he
speaks to Captain America and Captain
America says that they've lost the trace
of dr. Midas in addition they can't find
the mindless ones apparently Iron Man
has lost track of their of their scent
more or less or the ability for him to
to locate them and so for the most part
they are right back at square one what
we also see here is that as a result of
the orb
bringing everybody's secrets into the
light a multitude of the superheroes
about half of the superheroes have run
off they've gone to different locations
we don't really know what they're doing
all we really know is that they've
disappeared but most likely they're
trying to deal with this idea that
secrets they were previously unaware of
are now common knowledge in addition we
see that Nick Fury is examining the eye
of the watcher the eye that he had
gotten from the orb and what he says
here is that this thing seems to be a
living storage device and of course this
information came from Reed Richards that
everything The Watcher sees is quite
literally recorded within the eye itself
and that when the orb had I guess
exposed everybody secrets that it was
like filling a series of grenades and
that everybody was previewed to
everybody's information but what we also
see is that he again continues to
examine he says the good news here is
that only people who are in the
immediate vicinity were affected maybe
the entire world has not been made aware
of everybody else's secrets but he says
the bad news here is that half their
team is gone from here we also see that
Nick Fury asks an interesting question
he asked Captain America what it was
that he saw when he was exposed to the
secrets that he didn't that he wasn't
aware of but what we see Captain America
say is that he's not going to tell him
that it's not part of the mission from
here what we see is that again Nick Fury
kind of talking to himself while at the
same time talking Captain America he
said that it's a little strange here
that Captain America wouldn't give him
any information wouldn't tell him what
it was that he saw because as far as
Nick Fury knows
Captain America doesn't have any secrets
but Nick Fury says he has a lot of
Secrets as he has all kinds of
information and the question is why
didn't he see anything when he was
exposed to the eye of The Watcher from
here we transitioned back to Kimora Moon
Knight and Bucky Barnes and what we see
here is that they've traced the location
of these bullets to a planet and as
they're investigating this planet
they're trying to figure out what in the
world's going on it for the most part it
appears that somebody has managed to
kill an entire planet somebody has quite
literally shot bullets into the planet
itself but they can't really figure out
why they say that as far as I can tell
the radiation levels on this planet are
extremely high and so it's quite
possible that it's
Tom or another civilization inhabited
this planet and the civilization itself
had been wiped out but what we see here
is that there's no signs of any kind of
civilization having been there there's
no signs of former settlements that if
an individual had arrived on the scene
arrived on the planet and annihilated
the entire civilization there would be
structures there would be something to
indicate that people had lived here in
addition we see that Bucky Barnes is
able to dig out one of the bullet
fragments or else are a full bullet
rather and he begins to say that these
are bullet holes that the planet itself
is completely shot and riddled with
bullets and that only two circumstances
are most likely either this individual
was a terrible shot because he shot
straight down into it or he was
intending to shoot straight down into
the planet in which case the question
has to be asked why from here we see
that Bucky Barnes is able to piece
together this puzzle and he tells them
to initiate a camera to throw a camera
and to orbit around the planet and what
we see here is that as the camera begins
to to shoot around that of course Gamora
and Moon I'd ask him what what he's
doing this for that if a planet's dead
they really serve their purpose there's
really nothing else to investigate here
but what we see is that as a planet
I'm sorry as the camera begins to pan
around along the the bright side of the
of the planet that the planet itself is
revealed to be a living planet more
along the lines of something like ego
the Living Planet or something similar
which of course is very interesting here
because what this tells us is that this
individual that's been killing a
multitude of aliens has in fact killed
an entire planet which would require a
vast array of both power and prodigious
skill in using various forms of weaponry
from here we transition back on the the
surface of the planet with Bucky Barnes
Gamora Moon Knight and what we see is of
course they're shocked to see that this
individual or this entire planet has
been eradicated that this is this entire
planet has been killed by presumably one
individual and what we see is that Bucky
Barnes is again able to piece this
together Bucky Barnes says that this
narrows down the list of people who are
capable of doing something like this
this narrows down the number of people
who are able to achieve a feat like this
and so their list of suspects becomes
much smaller than it was before but we
also see here
is that Bucky Barnes sabotages the
spaceship and leaves Gamora and moon
Knights stranded on the planet and with
no real means of escape now we will see
them return but for the most part as far
as we're concerned in this story we
don't really know what's going to go on
with them we don't know if they're
actually gonna make it back or not from
here we see that the idea and the mind
of Gamora is that Bucky Barnes is a
prime target that Bucky Barnes is by
virtue of sabotaging their spaceship the
I guess enemy number one he's the most
logical person to have committed this
act in the first place and that he was
simply just hiding among their ranks
from here we transitioned again back to
two Nick Fury and we see that Wolverine
reports to Nick Fury's saying that the
orb will not divulge any of his
information to anybody except for Nick
Fury and Nick Fury says that's what he
was afraid of he says that he was afraid
that the orb would only want to talk to
him as opposed to talking to anybody
else now we don't really know why but
that's simply just the case as far as a
Marvel has explained it to us what we
also see here is he's asking the
question of himself that this is an eye
a single eye that's full of secrets but
the last he checked the watcher had two
eyes so the question comes what happened
to the other one does somebody else have
the other eye at this point we see the
Bucky Barnes teleports to where Nick
Fury is currently located and Nick Fury
is a little shocked to see this Nick
Fury didn't actually expect to see Bucky
arrive but he asked Bucky word is that
he came from and Bucky immediately
without any questions whatsoever
shoots Nick Fury from here we transition
to Nick Fury on the ground unconscious
at Nick Fury of course I'm sorry not
unconscious bleeding and injured and we
see him asking Bucky why it was it he
did this why would he shoot him
Bucky says no more hiding Bucky says
that there's no more running from our
sins he says that there's no more
turning a blind eye here and he in
effect decapitates Nick Fury and simply
says no more secrets at this point we
bring an end to original sin issue
number three and I hope you guys enjoyed
it from here we'll continue this
investigation and turn
the original sin storyline but what
we're going to do is we're going to be
v8 and we're going to talk about a
couple of the times we're going to talk
about Iron Man vs. Hope and we're going
to talk about spider-man
but that means said I will see you guys
in the next video peace